nous sommes avec frédéric français
membre du collectif 19 collectif de
riverains du 19e contre l'insécurité et
l'insalubrité les incivilités et le
crack bonsoir frédéric foncel merci
d'être avec nous à vos côtés pierre
henry président de france fraternité
bonsoir à vous aussi merci d'être là les
trafiquants de drogue ciblés par les
riverains donc plus de recours ni de
confiance en la police une situation on
sent qu'il peut dégénérer avec des
livres 1 qui se font désormais justice
eux-mêmes frédéric france elle alors pas
tout à fait je pense pas qu'on puisse
parler réellement de se faire justice
soi même c'est plus en fait une
[Musique]
le fait d'être a excédé quoi part par la
présence en fait de tous ses dessous
tous ces toxicomanes et de tous ces
dealers qui fait que les les riverains
en fait on a envie de les chasser e par
tous les moyens mais pas vraiment en
fait de se faire justice soi même ce
qu'ils veulent en fait c'est vraiment en
fait être entendu par la police par les
pouvoirs publics par les associations et
bien en fait que tous ces gens
comprennent en fait qu' on ne peut pas
accueillir tous les soirs du 2 des
centaines de toxicomanes en bas de ses
fenêtres sans pouvoir réagir que on a
envie de dormir parfois et oui on vous
comprend bien
pierre henry président de france
maternité à vous gérez les questions
évidemment des migrants il y en a
beaucoup dans ce quartier est ce que on
peut lier les les deux phénomènes
clairement on ne peut pas du tout lié
les deux phénomènes se cette question du
crack est présente à paris depuis des
aînés et il faut bien dire que les
pouvoirs publics en général sont en
échec sur cette question je comprends
l'énervement
l'exaspération des riverains mais les
enfants lorsque j'entends dire où aller
chasser par tous les moyens
j'invite évidemment à la réflexion il y
a un plan de craquer a été mis en place
à paris qui ne donne pas encore toute sa
mesure et qui en gros nous dit quoi nous
dit qu'aujourd'hui il ya une salle de
consommation pour 12 millions
d'habitants
en ile de france et il faudrait d'autres
salles de consommation sécuriser les
fameuses salles de shoot 1 dont il y en
a une oui mais c'est des salles de
consommation sécurisées et il y en a
qu'une qui aujourd'hui se trouve aux
alentours de l'hôpital lariboisière qui
pose des problèmes d'ailleurs à
l'environnement parce que encore une
fois vous avez une seule salle de shoot
pour 12 millions d'habitants en ile de
france
ensuite vous avez introduit un lien
entre migrants et consommateurs et
dealer de crack qui n'a strictement rien
à faire là en l'occurrence vous avez une
population migrante qui parfois peut se
retrouver en situation de précarité qui
touche proies faciles pour l'ensemble
des dealers il n'y a pas d' amalgame à
faire mais je comprends encore une fois
l'agacement je crois pas cependant que
se faire justice soi même
soit une solution république et je pense
que c'est autour d'une table avec
l'ensemble des autorités concernées
qu'il faut trouver une solution au plus
vite
et cette solution elle réside à la fois
dans la prise en charge des toxicomanes
avec des moyens
adaptée elle réside dans la chasse aux
dealers et dans la mise en place d'un
véritable plan d'hébergement qui ne
laisse aucune personnes précaires à
proximité de ces dealers mais qui sont
des proies faciles
frédéric france elle vous comprenez les
arguments de de monsieur pierre henry
vous êtes en accord avec lui sur le
terrain qu'est ce qui se passe
concrètement parce que c'est vrai que ce
plan crack il a été quand même lancée il
ya maintenant deux trois ans
manifestement il ne porte pas ses fruits
qu'est ce qui coince sur le terrain
alors sur le plan du plan crack ce qui
pose souci essentiellement c'est plus et
que les associations même si elles
interviennent sur le terrain
effectivement en fait n'interviennent
pas réellement pour les sortir de leur
toxicomanie
ils interviennent en fait pour les aider
à ne pas en fait avoir de nouvelles
maladies en fait part à leur
consommation c'est-à-dire en leur
donnant en fait du matériel stérilisé en
leur donnant en fait des moyens sera en
fête pour pouvoir consommer pour pouvoir
consommer il rapporte également fait de
nourriture de façon plus ou moins
sauvages en fait c'est qui les fixent
aux filles à certains endroits mais les
ans site en fait à se concentrer encore
plus et ensuite et surtout en fait le
gros problème en fait c'est qu'il n'ya
pas de suivi c'est à dire qu'on fait moi
je les vois en fait très clairement
depuis ma fenêtre très régulièrement
quand il ya des distributions les les
toxicomanes arrive prennent leurs kits
et repartent aussi vite
il n'y a pas de discussion fait avec
l'association il n'y a pas au fait de
d'interactions
j'ai même vu en fait la preuve le coup
en fait en étant descendu lors d'une
distribution de l'adra en fait c'est
donc une autre association humanitaire
j'ai descendu en fait j'ai vu les
toxicomanes traité en fait les bénévoles
en fait de l'association à la limite de
comme si c'était en fait
leurs obligés c'est à dire ouais donne
moi en fait du car on ne voit tapas de
40,2 quoi sur mes chaussures
ce n'est pas que c'est un droit
n'importe quoi je me casse comment est
ce que ça veut ça n'est pas normal de
parler comme ça en fait aux associations
et c'est surtout en fait on voit bien
qu'il ya un gros problème c'est à dire
qu'il leur fournisse serbe ce dont ils
ont besoin pour survivre mais n'essayez
pas de les sortir en fait de la de la
rue ils les entretiennent dans la rue
surtout ça oui oui personne n'entretient
les les toxicomanes les personnes
malades dans la rue la vérité c'est que
vous ne pouvez pas contraindre ces gens
à suivre des programmes des processus de
désintoxication
s'il ne veut ne le veut pas et que par
ailleurs les news - parrot j'ai tant qu
il sent qu'il ya des lois que la
consommation de drogues en fait n'est
pas autorisée en france qui s'en fait il
ya quelque chose à faire quand même
je veux bien en fait qu'on peut on ne
puisse pas en fait les obliger à fait à
se sortir de la toxicomanie en revanche
en fait il semble qu'il ya un moyen
aussi de leur demander de ne pas le
faire en pleine nuit de la rue mais il y
a de toute façon à trouver une solution
et c'est aux autorités à la au préfet de
police à la mairie de paris de trouver
cette solution en liaison évidemment
avec les usent les les riverains ça
paraît tout à fait évident nous n'avons
fait collectivement que déplacer le
problème depuis trois ans le nil et les
toxicomanes se trouvait sur une colline
appelé d'ailleurs le lieu dit appeler la
colline à la porte de la chapelle la
fermeture la colline à la porte de la
chapelle a contribué simplement à
disperser les populations et
sont venues se regrouper pour partie à
stalingrad sous les fenêtres de ce
monsieur et de l'environnement et je
comprends la difficulté mais je voudrais
que l'on entende la chose suivante à
partir du moment où on veut traiter le
problème comme cela s'est fait dans
d'autres capitales dans le monde entier
il faut d'autres salles de consommation
sécurisé et réparties dans l'ensemble de
l'ile-de-france est par ailleurs très
clairement je répète il faut évidemment
traquer les dealers faut arrêter que ce
lieu qui est un staline date devienne un
lieu de rendez-vous pour l'ensemble des
consommateurs de france voire d'europe
ce n'est pas possible c'est pas une
destination touristique et donc c'est
autour d'une table qu'il faut trouver
les solutions et donc j'invite ce
monsieur qui représente aujourd'hui les
riverains à un dialogue apaisé il faut
trouver une solution et manifestement
tiré au mortier sur pardonnez-moi mais
mêlée ce cas là pour défendre ce
monsieur parce qu'il est là tout seul
pour se défendre mon fils mais rim a
plutôt l'air plutôt pacifique a priori
et quand on a voilà ce genre de problème
et qu'on n'arrive pas à dormir de la
nuit on imagine que c'est une situation
qui est très compliqué est-ce que vous
vous sentez clairement non seulement ce
pacifique par les pouvoirs publics est
ce que captain stalingrad est clairement
devenu une zone de non droit comme on la
décrit parfois de l'enrobé 16 sur les
propos de van houtte est oui
fred-lille france elle vous avez ce
sentiment là vous oui moi
personnellement j'ai ce sentiment là je
vais vous expliquer pourquoi entre
autres c'est que je suis allé au contact
en fait justement en fait de ces
personnes toxicomanes
pour une fois on fait effectivement j'ai
vu en fait une fois en fait dans le parc
chez moi une personne en fait qui était
visiblement toxicomanes qui était
visiblement sorti de l'hôpital en fait
certainement par une fenêtre ou d'une
manière détournée puisqu'elle tu as
encore habillées en tenue d'hôpital et
elles étaient couvertes en fait d'une
maladie je suis pas médecin mais il
semblerait que ça soit une sorte de
l'est prophète très contagieuse dont
elle était couverte sur surtout le crâne
je suis descendu je me suis dit ce n'est
pas possible en fait de laisser une
personne comme ça en fait déambuler dans
le parc
il faut que quelqu'un l'aide donc je
suis descendu je me suis approché j'ai
demandé en fait si quelqu'un à
connaissez s'il y avait moyen de faire
quelque chose pour elle l'a en fait j'ai
été entouré par en fait donc une dizaine
de personnes toxicomanes qui m'ont
bizarrement en fait entourer pour me
protéger pour me laisser parler avec
cette personne là j'ai discuté avec
cette personne là est bien mais n'ayant
aucun autre moyen j'ai pris mon
téléphone et j'ai donc appelé les
pompiers
les pompiers m'ont dit monsieur en fait
c'est une toxicomane laissez la
tranquille
rentrez chez vous j'ai fait c'est pas
possible donc j'ai appelé la police
la police simon ni monsieur veuillez
laisser les greens d'urgence tranquille
on va pas se déplacer c'est une
toxicomane
laissez la tranquille remarque je sais
c'est pas acceptable en fait ça vous
avez des personnes en fait en grande
souffrance qui sont dans le parc et nous
riverains en fait quand on essaye
d'intervenir de les aider d'une manière
ou d'une autre ont fait eux ont déjà on
n'en a pas les moyens
et en plus quand on essaye d'appeler à
l'aide en fait les services de l'état il
nous disait monsieur or accrocher enfin
que vous êtes gentil mais restez chez
vous regarder la télé et vous occupez
pas des gens dans la rue ce n'est pas
acceptable
ce n'est pas acceptable qu'il faut
absolument que non seulement en fait des
forces de police interviennent en fait
auprès des dealers mais que en fait les
forces gouvernementales je ne sais pas
interviennent auprès de ces personnes
toxicomanes pour les obliger
en fait tu as eu à se soigner ils ne
sont pas conscients fait qu'ils sont
malades
il faut les obliger à se soigner ils
sont gravement malade il met en péril la
santé et la vie en fait des riverains il
faut les faire soigner
merci en tout cas tous les matins
pardonnez mon avis
malheureusement la fin de cette émission
on est tenu par les un petit peu par les
horaires merci en tout cas tous les deux
frédéric français les pierre-henri
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
france